Hey, Conan O'Brien here, and this is
the Live 360 pre-show.
This is kind of interesting.
We are now in my Warner Bros, studio,
but what we're gonna do
is walk from the stage
over to Digital.
Digital is where it happens.
Let's do that now.
And now we are entering the Digital world.
Isn't this amazing?
You can see various digital
awards that we've won,
that are unrecognizable to me.
There's Webbies, and
there's an Emmy there.
I recognize an Emmy.
And then this just looks
like they took it from a car.
I don't know what that means.
Hey digital gang!
[Digital Gang] Hey Conan!
You're all on 360
[Digital Gang] Hey!
360 Live pre-show.
You're working on our website right now.
Yeah.
Team... How's it going?
Lotta clicks?
A lotta clicks.
And who's drinking this Tejava black tea?
Who's having...
Bley
Bley, why do you have this much Tejava?
(laughs)
Is there any reason for that?
This is a lot of Tejava.
What I like to do is like,
get iced tea and I use
the empty glass bottle as
a water bottle because I
don't wanna spend...
Too much.
(laughter)
Don't wanna hear any more.
Sorry.
Anyway, hello, how's it going over there?
What are you working on?
Thanks, I'm good.
I'm coming up with a
social plan for Comic-Con.
Social plan for Comic-Con.
Means nothing to me.
(laughs)
I don't understand it.
I know that you guys do a very good job.
Is it okay that I essentially
don't understand digital?
Is that okay?
(laughs)
Is it all right that I...
(laughter)
I mean, let's be honest here.
Why do I have to know?
I'm just Conan, and then
your job is to grind me up,
and turn me into little
cubits and send it out
into the ethernet, right.
Yeah. I think that the more you don't know
what we're doing, it means
we haven't messed anything up
in a big way.
Very good.
Say you name into the 360 world.
My name's Tory.
Tory, okay.
Don't be confused.
(laughs)
And Tory, what are you working on?
Just working on some gifs
Okay.
and things.
All right, and what is...
This is the back end
of the website.
Okay. Back end of the website.
What's this here?
What are you doing?
It's some hand lotion.
This is a hand lotion.
Why do you have the hand lotion?
Do you have dry skin?
Yeah (mumbles).
I have, I get, have
look at that. Look at my,
doesn't that look like
a mummy's hand
(laughs)
that was just taken out of
a tomb after 3000 years?
The quivering I'm adding.
How's it going in the digital realm?
It's going well, thank you.
Okay, you guys all say
that like you're prisoners.
(laughter)
Prisoners of war
in North Vietnam.
It's going well.
(laughter)
We're being treated well.
Let's talk digital for a second.
You guys work in the
coolest, most cutting edge
part of the business.
Why do you have a stapler?
(laughs)
Why would this be even necessary?
No one's needed one of
these in like 40 years.
Why do you guys have one?
Let's get rid of it.
Why do you have tape?
(laughs)
You shouldn't have tape.
Everything is unnecessary here.
This is, oh my God, Spry.
What is this?
Dental defense system.
(laughter)
You don't know what that is?
Well, why is this even here?
Whose is this?
Do we know who this is?
Yeah.
This should go.
(laughter)
This should just be gone.
Why do we have a Mennonite farmer?
Step forward.
(laughter)
Why is it, you look like you
just cam from a barn raising.
Why are you here?
Do you even understand the internet?
I do the tech.
You do the, oh oh, I know
The tech.
The tech, but that's all
you, but why you look like
you just walked away from
your butter churn to join us?
These are the creative young minds that
are keeping me relevant,
or so they tell me.
Funny when I go out in the real world,
fifteen year olds throw
rotten apples at me.
So, good job everybody.
No, I really do.
They're doing an amazing job.
I kid, I make a joke, but
we're going to Comic-Con
and it couldn't work
without the digital team,
or so I'm told.
(laughs)
I honestly don't know.
We probably have enough.
I could probably sign off now.
But first, I'm gonna
pour out Aaron Bleyaert's
Tejava juice.
Do we have a, oh perfect.
Thank you for helping.
Because this is way too much Tejava juice
(laughs)
for one man to have.